zurück bei Welt live mit einer
Messerattacke und das mitten auf einem
Spielplatz in Köln gehen mehrere Männer
aufeinander los sein 22-jähriger bricht
mit einer Stichverletzung zusammen die
Ärzte können sein Leben nicht mehr
retten
etliche Streifenwagen stehen auf der
Straße mehrere Dutzend Polizisten
sichern den Tatort und befragen Zeugen
tödlicher Streit in Köln unter mehreren
Männern ist es am frühen Mittwochabend
auf einem Spielplatz im Kölner Stadtteil
Ostheim zu einem Streit gekommen dabei
wurde ein 22-jähriger Mann durch einen
Stich in den Oberkörper schwer verletzt
trotz sofortiger ärztlicher Versorgung
starb er später in einem Krankenhaus an
seinen Verletzungen die Anwohner sind
geschockt es ist schon krass wie man
auch einfach sieht es ist eine fremde
Person trotzdem nimmt das einen mit
deswegen sitzen wir hier auch einfach so
als Respekt in Gedanken des Verstorbenen
der Familie gegenüber weil meine
Freundin hat ihn auch gekannt ich
persönlich nicht aber es ist einfach zu
sehen krass zu sehen wie schnell das
Leben einfach vorbei deswegen banalen
Dingen sag ich jetzt mal kein Mensch hat
verdient zu sterben eine Mordkommission
nahm die Ermittlungen auf derzeit
fahndet die Polizei mit hoch nach den
flüchtigen Täter rund 20 Streifenwagen
sind im Einsatz
[Musik]
unser Kollege dimit jetzt in Köln am
Tatort als an diesem Spielplatz dort
Dimitri was kannst du uns denn zum
Tathergang sagen wieso kam es überhaupt
zu diesem Streit auf einem Spielplatz
also wir befinden uns genau am Tatort
hinter mir links sehen wir auch da haben
Anwohner Blumen hingelegt bzw Teddybär
eingestellt es gab hier ein Picknick
gestern Nachmittag Mitglieder der
Großfamilie waren die anwesend und dann
soll es während dieses Picknicks
zwischen zwei Familienangehörigen zu
einem Streit gekommen sein es ging wohl
laut Augenzeugenberichten um einen
Sitzplatz daraufhin soll es wie gesagt
diese Streit eskaliert sein und der
unter den Verwandten und kam dann so zu
dieser Tat also Junge vom geht davon aus
dass ein Cousin eben seinen Verwandten
erstochen hat unglaublich das macht
diese Geschichte wirklich noch brutaler
und noch unglaublich ja das ist ein
Familienstreit war um ein Sitzplatz bei
einem Picknick ist der Täter Dimitri
denn schon gefasst
es stand jetzt ist noch auf der Flucht
die Polizei verhandelt wir haben ja eben
in den Aufnahmen gesehen 20
Streifenwagen waren hier gestern vor Ort
wie gesagt die Fahndung läuft momentan
können jetzt nicht sagen ob die Polizei
inzwischen im gefasst hat aber zumindest
heute morgen liefen die
Fahndungsmaßnahmen noch das ist
sozusagen Gestalt jetzt besonders
tragisch sehr kann a also das Opfer
hätte heute Geburtstag gehabt kannst du
das bestätigen und weißt du etwas mehr
über diese Familie
ja er soll heute also ein Tag sozusagen
vor vor sein also ein Tag nach seinem
tödlich nach dem tödlichen Angriff hätte
er seinen 23 Geburtstag feiern wollen
und wir finden uns hier in einem
sozialen Brennpunkt muss man dazu sagen
vielleicht kann das der Kollege kurz
zeigen wir stehen jetzt zwar hier im
Park aber rechts neben mir stehen sieht
man die Hochhäuser das ist wohl seit
Jahren in Köln und sozialer Brennpunkt
Köln Ostheim Gernsheimer Straße es kam
hier immer wieder zu
schlimmen Taten
Familienvater der schon hier ins Koma
geprügelt wurde Schießereien unter den
Angehörigen von von
rockergruppierungen bzw Attacken die
Familie soll hier wohnen in einem der
Hochhäuser und genau und das ist halt
direkt hier vor vor dem Haus wo sie
wohnen im Prinzip passiert der junge
Mann der 23-Jährige wird von also der
22-jähriger genau gesagt wird von seinen
Nachbarn und verw damals ein sehr netter
zuvorkommender
Kerl bezeichnet die der wirklich sehr
beliebt war bei den bei den Nachbarn und
die können das nach wie vor nicht fassen
was hier letztendlich passiert ist vor
allen Dingen wegen einer Lappalie die
dann dazu letztendlich zu einem zu einem
Tod führt
dimitrisäuble besten Dank von vor Ort
auf diesem Spielplatz 22-jähriger
gestern erstochen wurde von einem
Familien mit